curry spice sweet corn soup first The
Fragrant curry paste roast coriander and
cumin seeds until aromatic then grind
adding crushed garlic chili powder
turmeric and finely chopped Ginger bring
together with olive oil to form a thick
paste for the soup fry finely chopped
onions in olive oil
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and seasoned
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn then add whole sweet corn
kernels with some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
heat and is ready to serve
wonderfully satisfying curried spiced
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch